well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight for just about three
years since the day Donald Trump was
inaugurated the left has worked
tirelessly to end his administration by
non democratic means as necessary
very much including impeachment well
tonight they are closer than ever to
reaching that goal and yet in another
reminder that the human nature is more
complex than the human genome they don't
appear very happy about it
in fact the closer impeachment gets the
more despondent they seem as the Buddha
himself once noted man longs to drink
from the lotus blossom only to discover
its nectar is the most bitter of all and
so Washington Democrats are close to
tears tonight over impeachment they had
such high hopes for president Trump they
want you to know that they saw his
potential sure they could be mildly
critical from time to time but only in
the most loving way as a parent corrects
a child is an opportunity for
self-improvement because underneath it
all they were rooting for Donald Trump
from day one because honestly when you
strip it all away their Patriots - they
just want what's best for this country
but then tragically into the path of
their good intentions roll Donald
Trump's fateful phone call to the
president of Ukraine that changed
everything now Democrats have no choice
but to impeach the president the United
States sometimes you've got to overturn
a democracy in order to save a democracy
sad is health in fact it's enough to
make even a hardened political operative
like Nancy Pelosi a little emotional
watch her explain this is a very sad
time for our country I say this to you
with great sorrow and prayerfully but
first let me say that this is no cause
for any joy this is a very sad time for
our country it's really sad we have to
be very prayerful I pray for the
president all the time this is a very
sad time for our country this there's no
joy in this it's sad we must be somber
we must be prayerful and we must pursue
the facts further yeah it's just sad
there's no joy in this or somber were
prayerful that's the official position
of the Democratic Party on the question
of in peace but they rolled it out they
tested it this weekend the talking point
in the sunday shows and tellingly not a
single news anchor challenged them on it
strangely though no one seems to have
had informed congresswoman Rasheeda
Talab one of the party's most visible
members she's still selling t shirts
emblazoned with her most famous quote
impeach the mother effer you can buy it
tonight if you want apparently Nancy
Pelosi hasn't had time to call the
congresswoman and recommend instead a
weekend of contemplative prayer she'll
get on it at some point and God knows
what to let will say when she does say
what you will about celeb and her other
friends in the squad but there are a lot
more direct in fact let's just be clear
they're a lot more honest than schmaltzy
windbags like nancy pelosi they don't
even bother to pretend to weep and pray
weep and pray they're thrilled they're a
little closer tonight - seizing power
and from that perspective that is always
an unalloyed good they could care less
about the system they'd like to tear the
system down that's the point
Main Street Democrats meanwhile though
ever worried about what normal people
might think are still churning out
increasingly implausible lies have you
seen the latest tonight it's maybe the
best they're telling you that the
Ukraine saga is actually about national
security concerns watch that is classic
abuse of power which undermines our
national security this is as serious as
it gets a president has put at risk our
national security our president
sacrificed our national security this is
a very serious matter of national
security at the expense of our national
president knighted States is willing to
compromise national security the tipping
point is clear it was national security
full stop oh no security there's a
cousin of cortez who couldn't find
ukraine on a big tight map how did the
president jeopardize our national
security by delaying they say military
aid to Ukraine that jeopardizes our
national security yeah if anything
jeopardizes our national security it's
sending mindlessly sending military aid
to Ukraine in order to antagonize Russia
what do we get out of that quick what's
the answer oh there is no answer right
we don't get anything out of it at all
but of course no one in the press pauses
for 30 seconds to question the core
story at the bottom of this which is
we're sending close to half a billion
dollars in military aid to Ukraine
because why because a couple of neo cons
think we should please well we're at it
by the way another thing that puts our
national security at risk for real is
when you make it impossible for the
president any president to have private
conversations with his counterparts in
other countries with other foreign
leaders remember the closest the world
ever came to nuclear war was in 1962
during the Cuban Missile Crisis how did
that end how did it de-escalate what
ended when our president reached a deal
with the Soviet President Ikeda
Khrushchev secretly they made
concessions to one another secretly they
couldn't have done it in any other way
if there were self-righteous leakers
around in 1962 the world would have
blown up that's probably not an
overstatement so it's a huge problem if
this president or any president can't
proceed with the expectations that his
phone calls the core of his job will
remain private
and by the way honestly the Democratic
Party really cares about national
security the party that won't enforce
our border with Mexico there refuses to
important legal aliens convicted of
felonies yeah they're really worried
about national security
uh-huh this has nothing to do with
national security that's the most
annoying of all the lies it's about
power it's a paragraph and by the way
say what you will about Talab and AOC
and them and the rest of those
hyper-aggressive freshmen at least
kind of honest about that and there's
something sort of nice about someone
who's honest about his aims even if
those aims are disgusting and
contemptible and scary which power
grabbing is but at least you don't have
to wade through a bunch of
self-righteous air to get their bottom
line Democratic Party wants to pretend
the 2016 election never happened and to
make sure it could never happen again
as Washington expresses its fake
concerns about national security they
can't even pretend to be worried about
corruption at the highest levels nobody
thinks hunter Biden deserved hundreds of
thousands of dollars for a no-show
energy gig in Ukraine but nobody seems
upset that he got it anyway last week
for example Joe Biden told fox's Peter
Doocy that this was all aboveboard
because he never talked with his son
about what he did abroad watch I've
never spoke to my son about his overseas
but I know I know Trump deserves to be
investigated he is violating every basic
norm of a president you should be asking
him the question why is he on the phone
with a foreign leader trying to
intimidate a foreign leader you should
be asking him about what hunter Biden
was doing in Ukraine
oh wait that's what they want to impeach
him because he asked about it but the
question is as a factual matter well
it's just because this is a news channel
we will answer the question the most
basic one is Biden's claim true well a
photograph obtained exclusively by this
show not to brag but we did suggest that
claim might not be true the picture
shows it's on the screen Biden on a 2014
golfing trip with his son as well as his
son hunters business partner devin
archer at the time this picture was
taken both of them on the board of the
ukrainian energy company marissa